[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 6 novembre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 60 18 26
minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
cette édition
six femmes mises à l'honneur lors d'une
soirée à guyancourt elles sont venus
témoigner de leur parcours devant le
public à l'université versailles saint
quentin initiative du député des
yvelines à didier baichère 237
journalistes emprisonnés à ce jour dans
le monde c'est pour leur donner la
parole ainsi qu'aux auteurs en général
qui est organisée la semaine des
écrivains persécutés emprisonnés et
empêcher la 9e édition débute demain à
saint quentin en yvelines
et puis jusqu'à la fin novembre c'est le
mois du film documentaire organisé par
images en bibliothèques 3300 séance en
france et dans le monde pour découvrir
des films et échanger et des projections
sont prévues dans huit villes des
yvelines avant de développer ses titres
pierre bédier patrick devedjian
auditionné devant l'assemblée nationale
hier les élus ont défendu leur projet de
fusion des départements des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine un rapprochement
souhaité depuis janvier 2016 les deux
présidents ont répondu aux questions de
sept députés yvelinois et alto séquanais
sur l'inquiétude d'un si grand
département quelle place aurait-il au
coeur de la région ile de france
écoutez quelques unes de leurs épouses
nous avons fusionné nos services à plus
de 50% nous y avons d'ailleurs fait des
gains de productivité très important et
notre objectif c'est d'atteindre 200
millions d'économies chaque année dans
par le seul fait de cette fusion ça nous
a rendu aussi beaucoup plus efficace
pour nous département des hybrides on
voit bien qu'il ya un risque de
glissement de richesse et nous voulons
accompagner ce mouvement puisque nous
voyons bien que sa part naturellement
avec l'ogcn et que ce serait trop long
de vous l'expliquer mais nos populations
sont les mêmes nos entreprises sont les
mêmes nuno fluides sont les mêmes on est
les mêmes en réalité
[Musique]
le député de la première circonscription
des yvelines a souhaité mettre les
femmes à l'honneur et parler de leur
engagement
élu entrepreneur chercheuse six femmes
en tout yvelinoise ont été conviés hier
pour présenter leur parcours et échanger
avec le public de la maison de
l'étudiant martha panne de l'ue vs cure
retour sur cette soirée avec marylène
yapi chiffres seulement 17 % des maires
de communes sont des femmes les start up
fondée par des femmes enlevées que 2%
des investissements depuis 2008
des chiffres révélateurs évoqués lors de
cette soirée consacrée à l'engagement au
féminin organisé par le député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
le panel c'était aussi l'idée de montrer
des femmes de toutes maturités tous les
âges avec tous les types d'expériences
qui viennent environnement très
différent des yvelines pour montrer que
c'est possible de s'engager et que
probablement plus voir les femmes en
termes d'engagement fera évoluer la
cause de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
une soirée débat accueillis par
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
sensible à ces questions d'égalité elle
organise par ailleurs un cycle de
conférence pour présenter les recherches
sur les inégalités entre les sexes
les rencontres du genre l'engagement
féminin donc aussi bien dans la vie
universitaire que dans la société civile
c'est un des enjeux de
la mission parité de l'université qui a
vocation seulement à permettre
l'engagement des étudiants et des
personnels mais également des futurs
citoyens donc c'est important pour nous
de participer à la réflexion au delà de
l'enceinte de l'université
après les présentations des différents
parcours des femmes invitées des
échanges en lieux revenant notamment sur
la nécessité d'être accompagné par la
loi pour plus d'égalité et l'importance
de l'éducation comme levier d'action
pour le changement
il est important aujourd'hui d'avoir une
représentativité des femmes et de leur
donner un temps de parole leur octroie
n'y qu'on aille la chercher
et cette initiative a été pour moi
quelque chose de positif et allant dans
ce sens là une soirée pour promouvoir
l'engagement qui aimerait renouveler le
député objectifs pour la prochaine
attirer plus d'étudiants
les professionnels de demain et juste
avant cette réunion environ 30
travailleurs migrants sans papiers sans
indiquer si j'étais sont venus à la
rencontre du député leur objectif
interpeller sur leur situation et sur la
difficulté à obtenir une régularisation
particulièrement pour les femmes souvent
en emploi à temps partiel et précaires
elle et lui les a écoutés s'est dit prêt
à les recevoir à sa permanence pour
échanger avec les services de la
préfecture et les représentants des
entreprises concernées
toujours à guyancourt une affiche
publicitaire qui ne passe pas vous
l'avez peut-être vu cette semaine en
vous baladant sur le boulevard vauban ou
beethoven une publicité de la marque le
temps des cerises avec un homme nu le
postérieur barré par le slogan reprenant
de manière détournée la devise
républicaine et des fesses de femmes
moulée dans un jean laville de
guyancourt par la voix de son maire
françois morton a demandé à la société
jc decaux de retirer ces affiches un
courrier a été envoyé outre le
détournement jeu sites douteux de la
devise les
il dénonce une publicité sexualise hante
affiché à seulement une centaine de
mètres de l'école élémentaire francis
poulenc et les affiches ont finalement
été retirée ce matin car en fin de
campagne publicitaire douze mille mètres
carrés d'espacé à montigny le bretonneux
explo s'est installée dans ses nouveaux
locaux et les inauguré hier mardi
l'entreprise d'ingénierie spécialisée
dans la transformation digitale à
intégrer l'immeuble le carré programme
est de 20 mille mètres carrés à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération qui se réjouit de cette
arrivée d'un groupe international
côté expliqué l'installation était
désiré sur ce territoire deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien les
propos sont recueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude une entreprise comme
de près de 15 cents personnes qui
s'installent et qui est sur le secteur
de l'accompagnement du développement
numérique dans tous les secteurs qui
sont sur saint quentin à savoir
l'automobile l'aéronautique l'espace
donc voilà donc c'est vraiment en
cohérence avec ce fameux choeur
économique que représente saint quentin
aujourd'hui je veux souligner que
l'inauguration du car est une
continuation de notre histoire à
montigny le bretonneux puisque nous
avions déjà depuis de nombreuses années
une présence dans un immeuble de l'autre
côté de la voie ferrée nous renforçons
ainsi notre présence
un mot de santé depuis cet été la
résidence autonomie agents fourcassa
attrape expérimente une nouvelle
pratique
l'aromathérapie les résidents ainsi que
le personnel sont initiés à
l'utilisation d'huiles essentielles deux
appareils les propagent dans le salon
les couloirs et le restaurant un moyen
efficace de lutter contre plusieurs
facteurs mais qui reste tout de même
encadrée écoutez ses explications et
témoignages au micro de maxime abolin
dans la résidence il y avait des odeurs
qui sont pas toujours agréables qui sont
souvent liées au président qui
vieillissent qui développe des signes
cognitive la problématique de l'humeur
de certaines personnes en fonction des
saisons
donc là aussi je pense qu'on pourrait
agir
et puis enfin sur la problématique des
petits maux de l'hiver
depuis plusieurs années je prend
l'habitude de mettre une petite goutte
son oreiller qui me permet de
me dit entre tanger
mais poché et du rythme plus facilement
le sommeil
on les utilise parfois sans de bonnes
connaissances et c'est pas parce que
c'est naturel en fait que c'est c'est
pas dangereux
donc en fait tout l'intérêt pour moi
voilà d'accompagner ce projet c'était de
pouvoir encadrer de manière voilà
sécuriser le bon usage des d'huiles
essentielles aléas présentation à
présent dans ce journal d'un événement
la 9e semaine des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés empêcher elle débute dès
demain à saint quentin en yvelines
entretien enregistré à la mi journée du
7 au 15 novembre c'est la neuvième
semaine des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés et empêché trois temps forts
à saint quentin en yvelines et aussi des
rencontres au programme on en parle avec
jacques fournier bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur d itinéraire poétique
de saint quentin en yvelines qui
organise cet événement les objectifs on
les rappelle quels sont ils
faire savoir que la situation de
certains écrivains dans le monde est
tout à fait catastrophique écrivain quel
qu'il soit peut être romancier
journaliste bédéiste dessinateur de
presse ou autre c'est surtout montré
d'abord à des jeunes collégiens lycéens
étudiants la réalité de la situation là
on vient de l'annoncer par exemple que
la la turquie et 172e pays sur 180 sur
la situation catastrophique de la
liberté de la presse
donc nous on a vite des écrivains pour
qu'il rencontre du public et qui leur
parlent et qu'ils le fassent entendre
leur vécu mais parce que ça un événement
qui est bien ancrée à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines neuvième
édition c'est une bonne chose mais ça
veut dire aussi de l'autre côté
qu'aujourd'hui on peut être encore
importuné voire même pire dans le monde
pour pour ce que l'on écrit suis pour
que l'on écrit parce que l'on dessine
parce que l'on pense lorsqu'on
nous exprimer et moi j'ai toujours dit
c'est je serais très heureux le jour où
j'arrêterai de faire la semaine les
écrivains persécutés ça voudra dire
qu'ils étaient aucun écrivains
persécutés dans le monde
mais alors cet événement s'est organisé
en partenariat avec plusieurs organismes
liés à la maison des journalistes ne les
accueille
l'analyste exilés voilà la maison des
journalistes qui accueille des
journalistes qui ne peuvent plus
travailler chez eux ça fait des années
qu'on travaille avec eux on travaille
avec l'atelier des artistes en exil qui
a été créé et qui est codirigée par une
metteuse en scène très connu des saint
quentinois c'est judith des pôles qui a
beaucoup travaillé au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et au prisme
et donc l'atelier des artistes en exil
permet à des artistes de travailler de
monter des expositions de publier de
l'union actuellement en plein en plein
festival dans l'est de paris
on travaille avec amnesty international
des représentant local d'un mini 7 euros
locaux pardon d'amnesty international
viennent parler de leur de l'action
d'amnesty
voilà pour la défense de la liberté
d'expression
on a travaillé que le pen club français
qui va bientôt fêter son centenaire qui
est une institution créée par des
écrivains à l'issue de la première
guerre mondiale
voilà on a on a des partenaires et et
c'est très important de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur ces structures là qu'ils
savent de quoi elles parlent aussi et
vous en parler l'un des temps forts il y
en a plusieurs à saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est aussi traditionnel en cette
semaine ses clés les journalistes les
auteurs les dessinateurs qui sont
programmés sur cette seule aille à la
rencontre mais les jeunes ça c'est
important de du 12 au 18 novembre ils
vont rencontrer des élèves de 3e des
lycéens des collégiens on organise
je crois qu'à douze ou treize rencontres
qui sont prévus pour qu'ils puissent
pendant une heure une heure et demie par
les leur histoire on va pas le but c'est
pas de 2,2 de s'apitoyer mais de montrer
que derrière tout ça il ya des vies
humaines
là on est en pleine discussion enfin
gouvernement annonce aujourd'hui ces
mesures voilà pour les migrations ben
voilà on est on est en plein dans la
thématique aussi ces gens là sont des
immigrants vraiment ces données qui sont
chez nous ils sont inscrits chez nous
c'est pas seulement des migrants qui ne
font que traverser le pays
ils ont choisi pour la plupart du temps
la france parce qu'ils sont persuadés qu
ici ils seront entendus ils pourront
travailler ils pourront continuer à
vivre normalement et n'ont pas survivre
et donc on fait en sorte qu'ils puissent
voilà faire entendre cette parole qui
l'on a donné aussi nom parmi les
journalistes les auteurs qui iront à la
rencontre de ces jeunes notamment guise
fortunés dont bd m'backé jeunesse de la
république du congo le congo brazzaville
qui arrivé en france il ya un an
il est emprisonné dix-huit mois ça dans
son pays parce qu'il avait critiqué le
président en place
denis sassou nguesso voilà et on a cette
situation là elle se répète pour papa
divin qui et bédéiste et qui lui vient
de république démocratique du congo le
pays voisin
on a aussi moi même nous juana qui vient
du soudan mais qui a migré très très
jeune en libye qui avait suivi ses
parents et qui de a dû quitter encore la
libye parce que voilà c'est une la
situation fait que ça ne peut pas durer
pour lui il est poète aussi et
et on va surtout aussi montrer le
travail les dessins et des gravures d'un
magnifique artistes syriens qui
s'appelle najah al boukai naja a connu
la prison de en syrie c'est à partir de
jusqu'à 2015 fin 2015 et à la manière
d'un d'un d'un musique qui a connu les
camps de concentration lui a mis en
dessin ce qu'il a vu oui la barre des
choses et des choses dures à supporter
là on est en train de monter
l'exposition à mes collègues qui monte
exposition le 10 mai waouh ça fait mal
bah oui ça fait mal et on veut montrer
que ça peut faire mal et qu'il faut il
faut le montrer pour que les gens
prennent conscience de plus en plus on
en a tout à fait je veux dire on sait
bien que les gens ont cette intelligence
cette conscience ils regardent la
télévision et hagarde internet mais nous
on veut vraiment qu'il est il que ça ne
soit pas du virtuel qui le voit vraiment
cette douleur que les expositions dont
vous parlez qui sera à la commanderie à
elancourt du 13 au 17 novembre voilà
c'est ça très peu de temps de 14 heures
à 18 heures il y aura des médiateurs qui
vont expliquer la démarche de denat jal
de kayes et on va monter l'exposition
sera sera là aussi pendant la soirée du
cette grande soirée qu'on organise tous
les ans depuis neuf ans il faut savoir
aussi qu'on organisera une première
soirée le set qui déroule demain jeudi
voilà demain jeudi avec le poète et
performeurs hébergerait qui travaille
qu'à travailler au mali qui a travaillé
en haïti qui a travaillé en citant
sicile et en sicile et rencontrer des
rencontres et des exilés des jeunes qui
étaient là qui attendaient de pouvoir
aller plus loin dans leur dans leur
migration et il a écrit un texte
s'appelle karen c'est la carène du
bateau celui qui permet de traverser
toutes les mers du monde est accompagnée
du musicien olivier journaux qui est
bien connu du territoire puisqu'il
enseignants enseignants de musique à
l'école de trappes et du danseur jérôme
dorsaux qui fera la danse improvisation
ils vont donner à entendre ce texte une
partie de ce texte là qui a été publié
en sicile en français en italien
et on aura aussi la possibilité
d'entendre des collégiens du collège
ariane qui ont travaillé avec
hébergerait l'an dernier pendant toute
l'année et qui ont deux qui vont donner
entendre un texte ils ont écrit qu est
une sorte de prolongement
de karen de yves bergerette et tout cela
donc on le fait parce que pour moi tout
est lié comme on l'avait fait l'an
dernier le concert de de cathy grainger
lie à l'église de trappes
là on est aussi dans cette volonté de
faire entendre différentes voies certis
bergeret n'est pas dans cette situation
d'exil et mais il connaît le saumon de
là il le vit de l'intérieur aussi parce
qu'il a il est très touché par exemple
tout ce qui se passe au mali
actuellement il avait on avait montré le
travail qu'il faisait avec des pannes
paysans dogon malien il y a dix ans sur
le territoire est maintenant il ne peut
plus aller au mali la guerre l'empêchent
d'y aller il est quasiment condamné à
mort là-bas si les retourne et nous on
veut faire entendre aussi la parole d'un
poète et tout ce programme et à
retrouver bien sûr sur les deux sites un
kiosque presse qu y point fr et la
commanderie point s y point fr une
semaine qui se clôtura elle se
poursuivra jusqu'au 17 noms mais il ya
ce temps forts dont vous parlez aussi un
c'est cette soirée du 15 novembre à la
commanderie qui porte ce titre ma poésie
ne parle pas de son jeu toutes les
informations encore sur les deux sites
internet qui s'affiche merci jacques
fournier merci merci à télé 78 d'être un
partenaire
voilà depuis des années de ce que l'on
montre sur saint quentin en yvelines
et je rappelle vous êtes le directeur d
itinéraire poétique de saint quentin en
yvelines
merci grégory
[Musique]
retour en direct avec cet autre
événement le mois du film documentaire
se déroule partout en france et dans le
monde jusqu'à la fin novembre 62 séances
programmées dans les yvelines dont au
grenier à sel à trappes présentation au
micro de mathilde et demi dans le cadre
de notre petit tour hebdomadaire dans
les salles de cinéma du territoire ça
fait 20 ans que le mois du documentaire
existe c'est une manifestation nationale
qui met en avant les films de
documentaires
nous attendons à un petit peu
cet événement sur le mois de novembre
pour mettre en valeur les films
documentaires donc là on a pas mal de
film en stock au grenier à sel vous
découvrirez pour les soldats tombés qui
est un documentaire réalisé par peter
jackson donc le réalisateur du seigneur
des anneaux du hobbit
il a mis en couleur et la sono river
des images d'archivés de 14 18 de
l'armée anglaise c'est phénoménal
à découvrir sur grand écran je vous
propose aussi le documentaire course
là-bas
nous sommes donc à alep en syrie et ça
va être rétablie qui vient de naître et
sa maman
vie le siège au jour le jour et film
tout ce qui se passe avec son bébé et à
l'hôpital où elle travaille découvrez
donc pour sabah et pour les soldats
tombés cette semaine au cinéma le
grenier à sel et le mois du film
documentaire se sont en tout 3300 séance
en france et dans le monde 40 pays
participent à l'opération pour en parler
justin maignan bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
chargé de communication pour images en
bibliothèques qui pilote cet événement
20 ans pour le mois du film documentaire
ça représente forcément beaucoup de
projections beaucoup de partenaires ben
oui donc comme vous l'avez dit c'est
3300 projection donc si on multiplie par
20 évidemment ça a augmenté au fil des
années mais c'est vrai que si on parle
de chips est toujours énorme puisque
voilà vous l'avez dit c'est dans le
monde entier ses 2300 structures qui
participent à la manifestation
il ya vingt ans il y en avait 200 donc
c'est une grande réussite on est
vraiment content même si c'est un
travail acharné à la fois de nous est à
la fois évidemment de ces structures qui
porte à chaque fois vraiment avec
beaucoup d'énergie dans leur séance donc
avec une grande évolution pourquoi il
faut promouvoir le film documentaire
pourquoi pas parce que on trouve en tout
cas qu'il n'y a pas il n'est pas assez
visible
c'est vrai qu'à la télévision on a accès
à certains documentaires mais qui sont
vraiment souvent réalisé pour la
télévision mais en fait il ya une
production et surtout en france on est
assez chanceux production de films
documentaires qui est qui est assez
énorme mais qui souffre d'être assez peu
sur les écrans qui sortent quand même de
plus en plus en salles de cinéma mais
souvent dans des sorties qui sont un peu
confidentiel et en fait c'est vrai que
c'est un genre cinéma de fin de film qui
vit vraiment beaucoup grâce à tout un
réseau alors beaucoup de salles
évidemment engagé mais aussi en dehors
de salles donc beaucoup de bibliothèques
médiathèques les associations des lieux
culturels et pas que et le mois du film
documentaire c'est l'occasion de mettre
en avant ce un travail qui est fait
d'ailleurs toute l'année mais le mot du
toc c'est l'idée de voilà d'en faire un
événement devait faire un focus et
pourquoi pas organiser encore plus des
séances à ce moment là que le principe
forcément de découvrir ces films
échanger autour de ses fils mais aussi
de donner la liberté à ces structures de
d'organiser leur programmation se sent
alors tout à fait c'est une
manifestation qui est basé vraiment sur
la liberté de programmation
donc nous images en bibliothèques ont
hélas vendant pour accompagner pour pour
faciliter l'accès à des films pour pour
initier des projets et voilà si les
structures en ont besoin mais c'est
vraiment une manifestation qui repose
sur chaque structure chaque chaque
participant qui va créer son programme
choisir ses films en fonction de déjà de
ses envies de ce qu'ils aiment de ce
qu'il a envie de montrer à son public en
fonction de son public de sa structure
et c'est pour ça que ça fonctionne parce
que ça ne serait pas une bénéfice à une
manifestation qui vient d'en haut on va
imposer quelque chose mais c'est
vraiment ce qu'ils voient là adaptés à
chaque lieu et c'est ce qui en fait sa
grande richesse mais il ya quand même
1500 films différents qui sont qui sont
montrés voilà pendant tout manoeuvre
pendant ce mois 9 mois et que dans les
yvelines 62 science huit villes qui
participent trappe breux bouilloire
robert conflans sainte honorine
elancourt il ya il ya huit villes en
tout soixante deux séances sont au
programme et comment justement s'est
construit ce maillage avec les
partenaires ce réseau avec les
partenaires justement alors je pourrais
pas dire exactement dans les yvelines en
tout cas j'ai quand même regardé dans le
premier catalogue du mois du film
documentaire en 2000 il y avait déjà au
moins de participants dans les yvelines
alors qu'il participe pas cette année
mais c'était deux bibliothèques
c'est un travail qui alors nous on est
un réseau bibliothèque donc on est on
est très en lien avec les bibliothèques
et ensuite c'est un travail de faire
connaître grâce aux séances aussi
j'imagine des professionnels qui vont
avoir connaissance de la manifestation
des associations aussi on peut parler
quand même d'une association dans les
yvelines qui est l'association
contrechamp qui a aussi beaucoup oeuvré
ces dernières années pour pour
solliciter sensibiliser des structures
au cinéma documentaire et puis après
c'est parfois aussi des personnes qui
voient là au gaz ils misent une séance
dans leurs structures et vont aller
taper à la porte d'une autre structure
pour faire des choses en partenariat
parce que c'est aussi une grande force
du mot du film documentaire c'est que
c'est énormément de partenariat qui sont
ici entre les professionnels et
justement entre eux par exemple des
cinémas et des bibliothèques qui vont
voilà qui est quand même le partenariat
qui est très intéressant en fait deux
comment chacun va montrer des films
chacun avec ses contraintes ses
objectifs
et voilà il nous reste 30 secondes est
ce qu'il ya un coup de coeur de coups de
coeur ah oui arrière sans l'un de choses
magnifiques on dirait que je peux
regarder quand même là
les bibliothèques de versailles qui
organise une journée le 16 novembre une
journée cuisine avec à 11
une découverte de documents
exceptionnels autour de la cuisine de
leurs collections patrimoniales à 14h30
une conférence la science culinaire ce
livre est à 16 heures une projection du
film entre les bras la cuisine en
héritage et je trouve que c'était un
événement qui reflète un peu le mois du
film documentaire parce que c'est pas
que des projections
c'est plein de choses qui se passent
autour des projections
avec autour des rencontres et des
rencontres avec les cinéastes et
d'autres choses encore le programme
complet à retrouver sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
justin maignan chargée de communication
pour images en bibliothèques qui
organise donc ce mois du film
documentaire et les 8 9 et 10 novembre
le théâtre montansier à versailles va
vivre au rythme des années folles avec
sa dernière création est yes une
opérette en trois actes où l'intrigué se
déroule à paris londres et aussi au
touquet or ils iront assister aux
dernières répétitions dernières
répétitions au théâtre montansier de
versailles pour la nouvelle création de
la compagnie les brigands le début des
années folles à paris sur fond de lutte
des classes voilà comment on pourrait
résumer yes l'histoire mettant c'est
maxime fils d'un riche industriel
son père a l'intention de le marier avec
une femme que le jeune gamin n'a jamais
vu et donc pour échapper à ce mariage
il propose à sa manucure qui lui tombe
sous la main c'est le cas de le dire
d'aller faire un faux mariage à londres
puisque à l'époque un peu comme
aujourd'hui à las vegas on pouvait à
londres allait se marier ou divorcer
neuf chanteurs et trois musiciens font
revivre pendant près de deux heures
cette oeuvre de 1928 composé par maurice
yvain l'opérette peut sembler être un
jour un peu désuet parce que c'est vrai
que on a l'impression à l'opérette
d'avoir délivré un peu sage avec un joli
soldats qui va rencontrer une jolie
paysanne
là c'est un petit peu plus caustique je
trouve que ça ressemble plus à de la
comédie musicale parce que le rythme est
très swing et très dansant après trois
représentations en avant première au
public versailles et yes sera en tournée
dans toute la france pour terminer
direction la petite commune de réseau
dans ce village de moins de 1000
habitants mairie et école se partagent
le même bâtiment
une double fonction courante autrefois
en france mais qui se fait beaucoup plus
rare aujourd'hui le reportage de
gwenaëlle saintilan quoi de mieux que la
mairie écoles pour montrer le symbole de
la citoyenneté de nos territoires ruraux
dans les années 1880 les lois ferry
rendre l'enseignement primaire gratuit
et obligatoire et impose de disposer
d'une école publique et laïque par
commune s'ensuit l'obligation de
construire en plus une mairie les
communes rurales du parc naturel de
chevreuse font ainsi d'une pierre deux
coups et baptiste un édifice municipal à
la fois école et mairie
un inventaire de ces mairies écoles a
été effectuée par la mission patrimoine
du parc
la ville de réseaux a été l'une des
dernières à disposer de ce bâtiment à
double vocation qui a été construit en
1910 il faut savoir que
nous avions à vieux vieux bâtiment qui
datait du xviie siècle xviiie siècle et
qui servait de mairie et ce bâtiment là
a perduré jusque une damnée 1903 ou là
le préfet voyant les conditions
déplorables de la vie de nos écoliers a
mis en demeure la commune de construire
un nouveau bâtiment
seul problème c'est que la communauté
extrêmement pauvre et il a fallu près de
40 ans pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre si
la transition de cette mairie pour les
mettre en valeur les mairies écoles sont
construites en coeur de village puis
pour certaines communes la construction
d'une nouvelle école a donné une
nouvelle fonction à leur mairie pour
d'autres il a fallu agrandir le bâtiment
initial pour faire face à la croissance
de la population
physiquement nous avons exactement le
même bâtiment
au niveau des classes eh bien on a été
amené à créer une deuxième classe voire
une 3e place
on a créé une unité de bâtiments et une
unité architecturale entre ces trois
casses autre petite histoire ne que tout
le monde connaît c'est que les
directeurs d'école habitait dans la
mairie en réalité est que ce qui restait
pour les locaux communaux étaient
réduits à une voire deux pièces temps
qu'il a fallu négocier dans les années
90 avec le directeur de l'école pour
qu'ils puissent enfin nous libérer la
mairie et rendent cet espace au public
cet inventaire des mairies écoles en
vallée de chevreuse est disponible sur
le site internet du parc
c'est la fin de ce journal belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]